I don't like labels for me say I'm
transgender was just a thing to say
because it's it's what people want to
label it me as a female who's a male I
just wanted to ask if you thought about
perhaps transitioning to physically a
male it's not something that you've
thought about as you're coming to terms
with your identity now I haven't only
because with what I do as I was
explaining
I've explained it's like I've always
wanted a penis I always have because it
just makes dating easier I've dated gay
men and I this is what I founded people
in my video is when I date gay men a lot
of gay men don't think I'm I don't not
man enough because I don't have a penis
so the fact that you're assigned sex at
birth was female but in your brain you
feel male that to me meets the
classification for a transgender person
and you know to me it also doesn't it
doesn't matter if you ever have a
surgery it's not so much if you ever
have a surgery it's about the way you
feel like the first person from like
algae bt q that I don't know personally
on a personal level that's like accepted
me it means I'm Zack because I just so
many people think I'm like taking this
bit just so hard
[Music]